the iPad Pro is about to get one of its
biggest redesigns ever with breakthrough
technology that the tablet Market has
never seen before so let's go to the top
10 major changes that just might be
impressive enough to make you finally
upgrade getting right into the first
change we have a massive innovation in
display technology for many months we've
been getting leaks and rumors from
various reliable sources about Apple
working on a new hybrid dual OLED
display creating the ultimate display
that's only possible by stacking two
OLED displays on top of each other now
as you know Apple has refused to put
OLED displays on their iPads for a long
time and instead chose to go with mini
LED for one big reason brightness for
HDR content while many OLED tablets can
only reach up to around 600 nits or so
the current mini LED iPad Pro goes up to
1600 with a dry back of that glowing
halo effect due to the backlight zones
now OLED displays on the other hand
don't have that Halo issue so apple is
gonna tandem stack two of them to double
the brightness while also reaping the
benefits of the pure black contrast
levels and beautiful colors creating The
Best of Both Worlds but even better
they're using a combination of flexible
and rigid OLED Tech which will allow
them to make the display panel itself a
lot thinner which leads us into change
number two apparently the new iPad Pros
will now be even thinner than they
currently already are which is kind of
insane because these iPad Pros that we
have seem impossibly thin especially
when looking at the 12.9 inch model now
you might think that the thinness is
limited by the chip or perhaps the
batteries but no it's actually the LCD
display panel with its many layers which
need to be fitted together and the new
OLED display will be much thinner so I'm
personally excited for a slightly
thinner iPad now change number three is
something that I'm glad apple is finally
doing which is giving us larger displays
yes the new iPad Pros will now be sized
at 11.1 and 13 inches after being the
same for so many years and you might
think it's not that big of a deal since
it's only 0.1 inch larger but that's not
the main point of this change I
personally believe that the actual size
of the iPad chassis will stay the same
while Apple will reduce the bezels to
make them look even thinner and sleeker
which is a welcome change especially
since they're about to make the iPhone
15 Pro bezels super thin record breaking
as for change number four we have one
that'll be a massive deal for those
seeking performance gains which is the
new M3 chip now yes I've said many times
that the M1 and M2 chips were already
Overkill in terms of performance but the
beauty of the M3 is that it'll give you
even more performance while using less
power which will improve the battery
life which no one can argue against the
reason for that is that the M3 chip will
be the first chip in the series to be
built on tsmc's brand new three
nanometer technology which features a
big advancement in performance per watt
and now that the software on the iPad
Pro is finally getting better like
supporting Apple's official Final Cut
Pro and Logic Pro apps you can actually
start to make really good use of the
extra performance as well as being able
to play games at 120 hertz without
overheating issues now moving on to
change number five this is the one that
I've personally been waiting for for a
long time over a year ago there there
were many rumors of Apple redesigning
the iPad Pro and adding magsafe wireless
charging to the back of it with some
rumors including Apple working on a new
magic keyboard with macsafe charging
support well it turned out that we got
none of those rumored features with the
M2 iPad Pro leaving us with a
disappointing update but my theory is
that all of those leaked features were
simply delayed until the M3 iPad Pro
which we're about to get so yes I
believe macsafe charging is coming so
essentially you're going to be able to
grab your macsafe Puck and charge your
iPad Pro right on the back of it this
would make it super convenient to use
your iPad with macsafe stands which will
automatically recharge your iPad Pro
while having it conveniently mounted in
front of you and then this actually
leads us into change number six which is
reverse wireless charging now this
feature was leaked a while back by Mark
German and it basically meant that you
could charge other devices by simply
magnetically attaching them to the back
of the iPad Pro so for example now that
the airpods pro support Max save
charging you'll be able to Simply place
them on the back and have them recharge
even while using your iPad Pro as normal
or better yet you could charge your
iPhone on the back of the iPad Pro if
you really wanted to with enough
magnetic strength to hold it up and my
personal hope is that they one day add
Max save charging to the back of the
Apple watch Ultra as well now moving on
to change number seven we have something
that I'm 100 sure is coming with the new
M3 iPad Pro and that's a landscape
FaceTime camera it was definitely really
odd last year when the iPad 10 came with
this awesome landscape camera that
finally fixed the weirdness of looking
off to the side while on FaceTime calls
but unfortunately Apple left it out on
the iPad Pro for one big reason I think
it's because Apple didn't have room for
the FaceTime camera and all its sensors
and the wireless apple pencil 2 charger
on the side so they stuck with the
portrait camera orientation but now
they're finally going to be able to move
it over to the landscape side for a big
reason which leads us into change number
eight yes that's the brand new apple
pencil 3. this one was leaked a while
back by a leaker named Mr White and
while it looks just like the
pre-existing apple pencil it's actually
a bit different in that it's a bit
shorter now the real change is going to
be more on the inside of the pencil
where I believe the magnetic charging
areas might be relocated or split to
different spots so that they can fit the
FaceTime camera right in the middle like
they did before in a landscape
orientation since that's the only way
they're going to be able to make room
otherwise the only other option is for
apple to move the face type camera down
lower into the actual display area and
then add the dynamic Island from the
iPhone which would be cool but honestly
it might look a little bit weird on an
iPad Pro so it might make more sense to
just go with the new Apple pencil 3
route as for change number nine we have
leaks of a brand new 4-pin SMART
connector which apparently is going to
be for powering even higher power
accessories than what's supported right
now through the current 3-pin SMART
connector now some people were
speculating that Apple was going to add
the physical map Max save 3 from the
MacBooks over to the iPad Pro but I
think this could just be a more heavy
duty SMART connector that's going to be
intended to support better and higher
power accessories that need more
throughput like with the new magic
keyboard case and then that finally
brings us to change number 10 which I
believe is going to be some sort of
redesign now I know the bezels are going
to be thinner while the actual chassis
could likely stay exactly the same but I
have a feeling Apple will redesign
something major on this new iPad Pro
like maybe adding a rounded Edge design
like what's coming on the new iPhone 15
models or moving certain components
around or even adding a glass panel to
the back to support the Mac safe
charging feature now I don't know if
they're going to be sneaking in a glass
logo for wireless charging or simply
replacing the entire back with glass but
I have a feeling something is going to
be redesigned in some way to make it
look different and more premium so there
you guys go those are the top 10 changes
that are coming to the new M3 iPad Pro
with a likely release date in the spring
of
2024. so if you're as excited as I am
click that Circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one and definitely
check out one of those two videos right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
foreign